what is in this caramel it's got caramel
in it too today about to do those been
Reese's taste test we're gonna find out
which one is the best
which one's the kingdom races which
one's the Rhys champion Restall Rhys
ultimate I'm deeply passionate about
this subject I'm a big races head
they're never really is a reason to
choose but you know yeah I'm just gonna
do it so I started out being team pup
over team pieces and then I tasted the
pumpkin version like little pumpkins and
I was like wait this is better than the
cup and then I tasted the big cup with
the pieces in it now it's like this is
better than the pumpkin you're like so
so your favourites are just which
Reese's you had recently we're not gonna
have all we tried but we couldn't
because summer seasonal no pumpkins what
they're the past we're beyond exactly
you know when to see where they at but
if we're missing your favorite to the
video of you evening yes first up we got
the classic cut oh yeah classic for a
reason baby this bringing back so many
memories it's in its own oh we weren't
good at Cheers
Oh fine
it's your classic ratio like it's hard
to judge the classic because this isn't
the standard I know this is like this is
gonna be number one and we'll just see
if anything beats it you finish that one
not gonna I'm gonna go pace yourself
we've got a lot of fun to watch a try
next Reese's let's go Reese's stuff with
pieces now this is not the big cut but
it's quite similar this is like the baby
cut on the outside it looks the same
yeah we'll say presentation-wise we got
a little breakage look there little hint
of what's to come
fine we won't Cheers it's fine I want
shoes I just get so excited when this is
chocolate mm-hmm
is it terrible that I'm already like
convinced that this is better yeah oh
yeah oh my god yeah you're an agreement
it's copy you new in love with a little
bit of added crunch so I would say yeah
I would say it's definitely enhanced by
the pieces and it's one step above I'm
sorry yeah apparently it's really hard
to track down every single Reese's in
stores there's probably like over 40
variations moving on the white chocolate
version of Reese's have you ever had
this one no but I you know chocolate
operated white chocolate flaps so I'm
ready I haven't had this because I don't
like I don't think white chocolates
better than normal chocolate yay not my
favorite but it's good you can't go
wrong nothing's gonna be bad today and
then it overpowers the whole reasons you
don't have a you know symphony we're
gonna put that below the original yeah
next yeah so we got only apparently one
representation of the big cup family
because that rial who went out to go buy
them didn't find my favorite big cup he
just found his favorite big cup and then
was like that's fine it's not fine Matt
I wanted it ultimate Reese's Cup it out
man looks like there was a hiccup in our
big cups
[Music]
we're just really good my mind is going
a million places because so the crunch
though is much stronger than the piece
crunch mm-hmm and as you can see from
this cross-section it's just stunning
it's a it's a work of art really this is
great mouthfeel you know a nice pops and
crunches small burst of flavors almost
like when you eat the kids toothpaste
and have the little flavor and a little
flavor no oh you lost me at the kids
toothpaste yeah you have an eight kids
to space this might be above the stuff
with pizzas for me hmm so I might be
right
no you're only right because mine isn't
there I'm gonna give it the first pot
too so we're gonna put it here but with
an asterisk
yeah it should have been the pieces one
but you know the cookie crunch just
really but oh good so now I have do you
like these ones oh yeah this is a
classic right here think peanut
chocolate ratio feels a little different
I think I drank it below peanut butter
cups but above white folks that's fair
if we're talking about superiority yeah
you got handed to the original I mean
this is just derivative
there's other ones too this is
representing all holidays shaped Reese's
it looks more like a leaf like what does
this look like a leaf tree or I think
the mouthfeel is great I'd say I'd rank
it higher than the clasp penny I would
too after pieces in front of our closet
Wow we're like we haven't thought about
anything yet this sounds almost like it
could either be the best or it could be
like do you want to just split one
yeah what's gonna share it it's got
caramel curse curse this is really good
I think there's so much going on I don't
really taste a ton of peanut butter to
me wasn't like one of those songs and
rap songs where you're like oh I like
that rapper
I like that rapper I like that rapper
I've nothing like that rapper and then
you're like wait there's too many
rappers on this song it's too long
no one's getting a rap long enough it
hasn't taken the top spot for me to me
it's taking the last spot oh yeah okay
this is where we're disagreeing yeah it
goes down white behind not yield okay
yeah we need a tiebreaker here man yeah
nothing yeah
yes Wow Matt you burned me twice yeah
I'm like starting to get sugar high and
I'm ready for it
next it's three six gold pieces
it's the racist piece of pieces so we
got the Reese's Pieces the classic where
I like this better than I remembered
mm-hmm
these are great they really are really
are so much for you
you definitely are good you're amazing I
might put it after the classic I'm gonna
put it repple enough to eat the classics
but before that yeah okay bad golf team
okay have a good day
yes good representation this is gonna be
interesting
grab the gate because listen to Spanish
emphasis to white chalk this is really
I think it's better darker chocolate but
that's just because I'm a dark chocolate
seemed a chocolate on the regular
reasons is too sweet and this back would
be off rip it's probably gonna be above
classic so we're looking now I'm even
gonna punch it up just a little more and
put it right here I can't believe that
we're like so and right now I am a huge
fan of Nutter Butter oh and I forgot
about these oh it's me caused a rift
because that I might you this might be
an inflated ranking well I love Kit Kat
Kit Kat is pretty much this but without
peanut butter right looks like kind of a
big kick hat to me hmm
this is pretty good oh yeah everybody
that taking it gets bad too it is a
little bit like a kick-out I would say
it's not as firm as a KitKat is it's a
little softer yeah it's all there you
got your mouth feel you got your flavor
you got her subtle notes you know you're
getting ripe and getting your peanut
butter notes like I said right out the
gate west soon as that tasted it but
this is gonna be controversial NASA
that's where my potential pick right
there well cookie over the pieces right
there
cuz that's a Nutter Butter you like like
Reese's like this isn't bad this is
really good yes that these are also
amazing that
really hard oh this is amazing I don't
know if you were watching me as I was
eating that I know but I just I don't
know it didn't feel quite as satisfying
to me as either a KitKat or me yeah also
the difference and I'll put it right
above of pieces oh that's nice of you it
is milk chocolate peanut butter and
nougat so I guess a little take a bite
this is really good the chocolate on
tops like weirdly crumbly which is the
kind of off from the rest of the very
smooth like gooey chocolate that we've
interacted with but that texture on the
bottom though the nougat whoa but the
new in itself is a little too neutral
for me it's so neutral that it just kind
of flat lines the whole experience once
it's in your mouth here's my pic right
out the game that was thinking this mama
give you this I agree okay yeah but this
is super good but I don't think you can
beat pieces because you know since the
boat I've saved you know my white
chocolate from being lost and it seems
like y'all both are in agreement but
this is so good I'm willing to make this
trade so that's the tray we're gonna
make next
why this is a reason peanut butter cup
frozen peanut butter dessert now with
more Reese's peanut butter swirl wait
they have to like add four so that the
outer shelf has awakened come on die
tomorrow Mike no see I was thinking
about a magic show and then this got
like a fluffy peanut buttery ice cream I
think we're we're veering off into a
different land here because you could
pretty much go wherever with Reese's
they're like literal Reese's peanut
butter
that's breezes like mixes we're doing
that do more than close representation
this is this close yeah this is pretty
close to a cup and just like a frozen
fruit yeah okay where would you approach
your place see this is where it gets
hard the moment we start getting in this
land we're now wondering is it good
because it's recess or is it good
because that's a dang ice cream snack
that's your ice cream does yeah his own
game yeah that's amazing
I think I'm gonna put it above pieces I
don't think it's above original cut open
either let me just clarify though there
are no like losers all right from here
up it's amazing it and last but
certainly not least a deviation can we
say yeah from the classic but also a
classic in its own right oh yeah oh yeah
let's go
yeah zero huh okay would you say it's
almost unfair to try to pick this
Reese's puffs against its brethren yeah
now this one is it's above it you know
it's its own league right that'd be
number one or what that'd be no above
the big cup baby honestly this one
probably good good figure to leave it
but it makes more sense to rank its
brethren than it does to bring puffs
into this this Thunderdome it's just
living on its own plain looking down
upon the recess and thinking yeah y'all
good I'm good to sit yeah their final
ranking last chance to do any trades and
he swaps I think the only trade and swap
that come to my mind this guy with this
guy I think I got actually would be
willing to make it to anything let's do
it there if you had these on the shelf
next to each other I think I would go
for the dark chocolate races yeah before
the races with pieces all right so we
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve Reese's
coming in at 12 Reese's outrageous
number eleven Reese's white chocolate
cups number ten
Minnie Reese's Cups number nine weeks of
sticks number eight Reese's Pieces
number seven Reese's fast break
number six Reese's peanut butter cups
frozen peanut butter desserts number
five Reese is classic number four
Reese's Holliday shapes number three
Lisa's stuffed with pieces number two
Reese's dark chocolate number one
Reese's Cup a franchise race is big
congratulations to all the Reese's out
there for all of the reasons we didn't
get to taste today blame Matt I feel
like I don't need to have Reese's for
like another year but I have never felt
so successful I'm gonna go detox yeah I
think that's a good idea let's boot you
up good chap oh I know this looks a lot
like Eugene from tri guys's ranking
videos I really try to think of another
way to display our top choices and I
really couldn't be competitive this is
the standard way to rank something and
you know before YouTube that's how
things were ranked
[Music]